[Musique]
j'avais 3 avant que 10 en trois ans que
je mal où j'en ai marre d'être que je
crois si papa du rachat moi je m'en
fiche je quitte cette prison
le contre est fermé aux enfants nous
allons à l'école pour rencontrer des
amis de mon âge hier le nom de l'élève
michel du fonds qui est qu un vampire et
je veux être ton ami mario monti toi de
toi toi pas de raison d'avoir peur font
pas tes parents apprennent que j'ai dit
c'est maigre par an j'ai perdu mes
parents 28 zabym des rigolos perdu mes
parents c'est une expression ça veut
dire qu'ils sont noirs moment les
mouvements et bouge plus jamais non il
ne bouge plus nous c'est pas pareil
il existe des êtres sur cette planète
qui peuvent nous faire mourir vraiment
le djibouti en colère
on sauvera soit
je jure d'être un super tout un tout
petit vampire et de jamais dire que ce
plan qui s'y fie à mes copains si tu
sors pis il admis tu risque sa peau et
l'autre moussaillons on va l'autre au
barça chimie tout son mari
savoir michel jarry
les airs à partir entre goldex à cette
façon de lui n'arrivera pas à l'abordage
pour faire court sauver petit vampire et
éviter un châtiment est normal qu est-ce
qu on se mord aujourd'hui